strength counts when Russia's watching
this U.S aircraft carrier is operating
in European Waters in a deliberate show
of force
it's part of a NATO Mission that's come
into sharper Focus
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine
this is routine training for NATO but
should Rutter's war with Ukraine
escalate significantly Pilots like these
could be called upon to go into combat
for real
foreign
per visit the head of the alliance said
the goal is to deter threats
he shared concerns about a false claim
by Russia that Ukraine is planning to
use a radioactive dirty bomb on its own
territory Russia has accused others for
things they intend to do themselves so
we need to monitor closely what Russia
now do and uh and and and they must know
that use of a
dirty bomb order a radiological bomb is
is a serious escalation
with so much uncertainty the pilots
flying these f-18s face the possibility
of one day fighting with Russia in
air-to-air combat for real it's daunting
all we do out here is trained to get
ready for a fight that might come and uh
I mean I think when it becomes pilot to
Pilot I hope that we're The Better Man
in the Box in the past few days U.S
debts have flown close to Russia while
two Russian warships have watched the
carrier from a distance
no one wants conflict but everyone's
aware of the risks you're always ready
to execute
the full spectrum of maritime operations
so you'd be ready to go to war if if the
call came if we are if we are directed
certainly that's what we prepared for
but what we are also here is for um is
to
bring peace and stability because that's
what we do
the hope is that showing NATO is ready
and able to fight means it won't have to
Deborah Haynes Sky News on board USS
George H.W bush